my New York mother of three says her
family was removed from the JetBlue
fight in Florida because her
one-year-old kicked another passenger
seat cell phone video shows family
members confronting airline staff and
airport officials last month JetBlue is
refused to apologize Kris Van Cleave is
at Reagan National Airport outside
Washington so how this latest incident
shows how the airline industry is
pushing back Kris good morning good
morning you know each of these viral
videos brings with it the possibility of
huge social media backlash but here you
have an airline pushing back on the
family's account and what we're finding
for an industry that often sees itself
under the microscope for customer
service issues the airlines are
increasingly sending a message that the
customer is not always right
I'm not taking like what do want me to
do my grades I know I'm freaking what I
need us to do is come with me on set the
plane man de frost cellphone was
recording when a ground agent informed
her JetBlue was removing her family of
five from the flight in Fort Lauderdale
I need to get back to New York I need my
kids back she says the Airlines decision
came after her one-year-old kicked the
seat of another passenger but the
airline denied her account saying the
family was removed after a verbal
altercation that included physical
threats and profanities against a nearby
customer
it's the latest example of Airlines
pushing back rather than backing down to
customer complaints last week when Ann
Coulter launched a Twitter war with
Delta over a reassigned seat the
airlines shot back your insults about
our other customers and employees are
unacceptable and unnecessary and in May
JetBlue denied it kicked a family off a
plane over a birthday cake it's a bird
the airline said the family cursed and
yelled at the crew CEO Robin Hayes
defended his employees on CBS this
morning
it was not about the birthday cake the
crew have to maintain a great
environment onboard for all of our
customers in April United Airlines was
sharply criticized for being slow to
respond to dr. David a violent removal
from a plane in Chicago an incident
experts say provided Airlines with a
much-needed wake-up call
this human social media has changed the
way people interact with companies seem
like Airlines were you know falling all
over themselves to apologize for
absolutely anything you know whether or
not it was really entirely the airline's
fault and now airlines here just over
the past week or so having sort of taken
that back some wrought what and said you
know what the customer is not always
right
United CEO says the airline is working
to revamp its social media team to
respond faster but the number of
complaints filed by passengers against
Airlines appears to be surging when you
look at the numbers from May of this
year compared to May of last year
they're up about 57% Viana yet you're
seeing airlines continue to stand by
their employees Chris thank you